So, I first did my first talk about CSS Grid
all the way back in 2016.
At the time, it was only available in Firefox
Nightly and Creme Canary, so I was making
things that people could not actually see.
I was using a whole bunch of brand new CSS
features, leading-edge stuff.
Just experiment be making sometimes more abstract,
weird experimental layouts rather than real
websites.
It was fun but it's not something you can
do at work!
So now, of course, CSS Grid supported every
where except internet explorer!
[Laughter].
It's a little frustrating, definitely.
Around the same time that I was playing with
these brand new CSS features, I was reading
this book, so, it's basically all about progressive
enhance ment.
This is the idea that you can start off with
semantic HTML and you can sort of slowly build
in layers, and, once you've got that base
of solid semantic HTML, you just add some
CSS, you sprinkle on some JavaScript, and
then you've got a website that every single
person can use.
Back then, his example was radius, right?
At the time the book came out, this wasn't
widely supported.
Now, if you're on Opera Mini, even now, this
still isn't supported but you can use it pretty
much everywhere else, and, if you're on one
of those old browsers, if you're stuck on
perhaps IE4, I mean, on nature.com, we have
400 users on IE4, so these people are out
there somewhere.
I don't know what they're doing with their
life!
These people will see a square, and it's like,
okay, that's fine.
Let's take a far more modern example.
This is me - this is my personal website on
Google Chrome.
This is my personal website on Firefox.
In this will be my personal web on Firefox.
So there is a whole bunch of stuff we can
use without really worrying about it, without
caring about it, without thinking about it.
If it doesn't work, it doesn't matter, our
website is still fine.
Then we have layout stuff which of course
is less fine.
We have to wait until every single browser
in the whole world is actually supporting
this stuff before we feel we can use it on
a production site.
So this is back in the day in 2016, this was
- this was one of my first just little weird
experiments with CSS Grid, and so this is
what it looked like back then in Knightly,
and Canary, and this is what it it looked
like for everything else.
No thought into what what it will look like
in other browsers.
There are today some big websites using CSS
Grid.
This is the Guardian.
This is what it looks like in a browser that
doesn't support CSS Grid.
This is the Financial Times.
Again, using CSS Grid in this very simple,
basic way, not really using it for everything,
not really using it as much as it could do,
and then here we have the FT in Internet Explorer,
you can see that it looks pretty decent and
pretty good, but it is a different layout.
It is a simpler layout.
It does mean their sidebar is now further
down the page looking a little bit odd, but
it is still kind of fine, and I think if you're
take these two different approaches, of making
the website look exactly the same, and kind
of just making do with the best you can do
for Internet Explorer, I think this is only
the approach that is really worth taking,
because otherwise, what you're doing, you're
recreating the exact same layout in two different
ways, and I think a lot of us are just so
excited about using CSS Grid that we're like,
yes, let's just use it, and then we have to
deal with managers, when we have to deal with
product owners, when we have to deal with
QA, they're like, "We will make it look exactly
the same," and you're just sending people
more code, more CSS, and you're actually in
a way making things more complicated.
The whole reason we want to use CSS Grid is
so we can do more exciting and experimental
layouts, more artfully directed layouts but
partly because it makes our life easier.
As soon as you're writing two layouts to achieve
the exact same thing, you're kind of losing
all the benefit.
I think the reality is we are going to have
to make do.
This year is a third example of a relatively
large site.
This is Stripe.
Most of their customers are developers.
So they can be probably a bit more - make
assumptions about what browsers people are
using.
I'm sure their analytics show very few developers
using Internet Explorer.
If you're a developer who chooses that browser
out of choice, then I don't even know what
to say to that!
Firefox has undoubtedly what is becoming the
best tooling for doing layout stuff, and this
will actually show you every single use of
Grid on a web wage, so, this is Stripe.
You can see they've really gone to town.
They're using it all over the place to do
what is really a quite interesting layout.
I've got to say, I think it is one of the
best designs, websites I've really come across.
I think they've done a really good job.
But, unfortunately, you know, this is what
it looks like on internet explorer, which,
yes, it is not great, readable, legible, it's
not even usable.
So these are the statistics as they are right
now.
It's gone from being almost what seemed like
the only browser to a tiny three per cent,
somewhat depressingly Edge actually is still
used by fewer people than Internet Explorer.
Hopefully, we will see this drop down further,
but every single one of these people on recent
versions of windows do actually have the option
to open Edge whenever they want to, so I think
we're just talking about very stubborn people
like, "Oh, my God, please just open Edge."
Depending what your client - this is GitHub
as of this July.
They're going to completely stop supporting
Internet Explorer.
That's one choice.
If you're a content-driven site, some of us
are making complicated web apps, some of us
are to manage Google maps, very JavaScript
heavy.
If you're a content-driven site where you've
got a bunch of HTML, you can take this approach.
This is the Guardian in Internet Explorer.
This is nature.com in Internet Explorer 9.
To avoid that Stripe issue where you have
something completely illegible, something
completely and utterly unusable, instead,
you strip out the CSS, and you're left with
pure HTML.
It doesn't look amazing, but it will work.
I think going forward, as we see a further
drop -off of Internet Explorer uses, this
will become an increasingly viable way to
deal with old browsers, so this is just using
a relatively complicated media query, and
I'm not going to explain what all that stuff
actually means because it is kind of irrelevant.
This is basically ly a hack.
This will make your CSS appear absolutely
everywhere except Internet Explorer and old
browsers.
Because, we're not just talking about CSS
Grid.
When we talk about internet explorer, this
is a comparison of Internet Explorer 11 and
the latest version of Chrome.
If I zoom in closely, you will see this is
a list of every single feature that Internet
Explorer 11 doesn't support with Chrome does
support, and it's an ever-growing list, because
in Explorer right now, it's security updates
only, right?
So every single time I see discussion on the
internet about there's a new feature, everyone's
excited about it, there is always some guy,
can you use it in internet explorer?
To which the answer forever more is no, you
definitely can't.
And so, I'm sure in doing cross-browser test,
this is where I spend a lot of my life in
browser stack, opening various browsers, getting
my own mobile phobe out, which has got, like,
seven different browsers on it, because it's
kind of easy to run into a browser bug.
This is the working group, the CSS working
group of the W3C who are the people that make
the standards.
They kind of know what they're doing better
than anyone yet this is their website in Safari.
So this is why it can be such a good idea
to actually use this technique developed by
the BBC a fair few years ago which you can
update, just cut out Internet Explorer completely
because if you're not actively checking every
old browser out there, the chances are you're
going to run into stuff like this and not
know it and have unreadable, and illegible
content and unusable content.
I'm sure most of us aren't there yet where
we can just say you get some plain HTML if
you're in Explorer.
This is nature.com.
This is nature.com in Explorer.
You're thinking why even bother?
If you can do a layout with Flexbox, do it
with Flexbox.
I think when talking about how do you progressively
enhance a layout, how do you progressively
enhance the CSS Grid, if you're trying to
achieve the exact same layout, there's not
that much point.
This is CSS without CSS Grid, this is Flexbox
layout in Internet Explorer.
You can kind of tell why we actually needed
CSS Grid, right?
This is the kind of thing that was harder
to deal with, to actually have these consistent
columns.
In the last talk, you heard about app support.
I think the really frustrating thing about
app supports is you do have to find your pullback
layout first which is more counterintuitive
really than I would like it to be, so we've
got the margin for internet Internet Explorer,
styling for Internet Explorer, different columns,
and then you have to actually take all of
those things away and remove them, so it's
not the nicest code in the world.
Desperate to take it out of there.
But it can be done if you're happy with something
that isn't quite 100 per cent exactly the
same.
We're not using CSS Grid as some kind of developer
convenience to make our lives easier, we're
talking about less code, sending lows code
to people's browsers, actually
increasing performance, improving performance,
and, yes, making out as well as make us ourselves,
making all our lives a whole lot easier.
So these are some refactoring that I've done
relatively recently.
We did have some layout done in Kotlin which
I'm sure is relatively unusual and was a little
crazy.
As well as just JavaScript for doing layout,
which really obviously should be CSS's job.
There is still now, even though it has shipped
in most browsers, there are a whole bunch
of useful features we are waiting for.
In HTML, some stuff has to be nested.
As we know, I think the most obvious example
of that is the form element, right?
So you can't have a label, you can't have
an input without a form.
Every CSS Grid that kind of matters because
it is only direct children of a grid that
are actually going to be laid out in your
grid.
This is where just content will come in handy.
This is a slightly technical explanation from
the actual spec.
It's probably slightly easier to show a visual
representation of what that actually means.
Here's a rather contrived layout, a simple
two-column grid.
You can see the whole form is actually just
inside of one single grid cell, and however
much stuff I put in the form, it's all going
to be in a single cell, and as soon as you
put display contents on to the form, then
things will be laid out into the two columns,
and so that will make Grid a lot, lot easier
to work with for a lot of Edge cases that
you will run into.
That already has reasonable support.
I think we are waiting on Edge at this point.
So it is supported everywhere else.
This is the kind of thing I hope going forward
sub grids are help us deal with.
So, sub grid, I haven't been able to play
around with it because it's not actually supported
in any single browser in the whole world yet.
But, you can see those are two grids here
almost.
You've got the cards, but then the actual
inside of the cards are also equal to one
another, and that's something that, at the
moment, unless you use specific heights, and
you actually just say, "This is going to be
this many pixels high", you can't really get
that effect, and that obviously means you've
got the potential for truncating content,
for content being completely cut through.
Generally, something to avoid, so, sub grid
is really going to help us with that hopefully
when it is implemented.
It's not all completely panned out yet in
the spec, but achieving this sort of layout
should be as easy as "display sub grid".
All those examples we've actually seen of
the big production websites of using Grid
have been very, very simple - put a side bar
to the side, simple layouts - which is a shame,
because I think Grid is such an intuitive
and useful way to set out layout, and the
first time I actually started reading about
Grid and thinking about Grid, everything was
saying you use Grid for things that are in
two directions, right?
Then you use Flexbox if it only goes in one
direction.
Actually, Grid is so powerful that a lot of
time, it is more - it's actually superior
to Flexbox even for these one-dimensional
layouts.
So we could use Grid throughout our whole
website, but we're probably not really there
yet.
If you to want to learn more about progressive
enhancement and dealing with Internet Explorer,
I do have a whole article about that.
And thanks!
[Applause]